bonjour eric valère oui bonjour bonjour
aux auditrices et auditeurs de
martinique et surtout l'amandinois
martinique 1ère et la montée doit
surtout et je souhaite les meilleurs
voeux à tous et toutes celles qui musée
qui m'écoutent en ce moment très bien
eric valeur alors c'est la quatrième
candidature au lamentin donc vous vous
étiez déjà présenté en 2014
c'était donc votre troisième tentative
et vous aviez obtenu un siège avez vous
siégez justement au cours de la
mandature en tant que conseiller
municipal où est jugé plus que siéger
parce que effectivement je crois pouvoir
dire vous pouvez faire un micro trottoir
l'action que j'ai menée tout en étant
élu minoritaire au sein de la
municipalité est vraiment remarquable je
crois pouvoir dire que j'ai pu rouaix
aussi enrichir les délibérations tentant
commission puisqu'il s'agit d'un trois
commissions que au sein des séances du
conseil municipal et j'étais vraiment
régulier alors qu'est ce qui vous laisse
penser que cette fois ci pourrait être
la bonne pour être élu maire au lamentin
je ne pense rien du tout tout simplement
je suis en mission je poursuis ma
mission je suis mes dépenses est ample
et conditions de la passation de pouvoir
entre pierre samot et david zobda est ce
que ça peut être par exemple
non mais je les dis que je l' ai dit
lors de la passation de pouvoir s'est
félicité david zobda je lui ai dit tout
simplement que je n'aime pas trop les
cérémonie d'adoubement nous ne sommes
pas dans des féodalités et rendez vous
devant la population
et puis je crois que les électeurs
électrices laventinois les citoyens ont
besoin de mer qui les aiment et j'en
profite pour dire comme pierre samot les
a aimés
que présentez nous un peu votre liste
avez vous changé un peu les effectifs
vos colistiers puisque vous en êtes à
votre quatrième candidature
quel est son nom est vous soutenu par
tel ou tel parti est le parti de
l'échiquier politique je suis je suis
personnellement membre du rassemblement
démocratique pour la martinique et
amundi
mon parti me soutient tout naturellement
je suis au dessus un des querelles de
personne car vous savez la politique
pour moi je la place à un autre niveau à
notre échelle nous connaissons les
grosses difficultés de la martinique la
martinique est en grande difficulté et
bien malin celui qui candidat à la tête
d'une municipalité pourrait dire écoutez
moi j'ai la baguette magique je vais
pouvoir faire mieux que celui qui m'a
précédé
je crois que la martinique a besoin de
s'orienter
le lamantin singulièrement vers un autre
paradigme c'est à dire en fait quand
nous partirons à partir du 15 mars au
soir 2020 quand une partiront de chez
nous nous partirons tous peuples unis
l'amandinois avec notre coeur ne le
laisseront pas sur le lac au mode
alors si vous êtes élu justement au mois
de mars pour vous concernant le lamentin
qu'est ce qui pourrait être la priorité
d'un nouveau maire aqua devrait-il
s'attaquer en premier bien çà mau je le
cite encore une fois a eu l'occasion
avant de passer la main de me dire
énormément soutien sur deux projets et
je pense que ces projets là doivent en
priorité avait été longtemps son
opposant politique à pierre sans bruit
mais je droit il faut le dire
en 2008 je n'ai pas été opposant puisque
je n'ai pas présenté de liste aux
municipales cela m'a coûté puisque entre
temps deux trois candidats ont pris au
mot ni un petit peu mon électorat
on va dire 2014 c'est un nouveau départ
et là j'ai de gros espoirs ou 2020
puisqu'un il y aura moins de liste moins
de concurrents alors je cas pour celles
qui se sont déjà déclarés et puis c'est
dans la concorde
je ne me présente pas un meilleur que
les autres
je vous demandais si vous étiez élu quel
serait le dossier vous auriez souhaité
traiter ans et liam alors moi j'ai ma
vision est déjà il ya un gros dossier
c'est tout l'aménagement de la place
ducale d'acier qui relie on va dire la
place en face de l'église du lamentin et
jusqu'au la gare routière de du tcsp
proches estiment que là il ya un
formidable espace aménagé ça va coûter
très cher parce que je considère que ça
doit être une esplanade à une esplanade
et qui va ramener à trois niveaux et le
dernier niveau nous ramenant au niveau
de la place andré dubuc donc ça va être
de gros aménagements il y aura la
possibilité aussi de parking de telle
sorte que l'on puisse recommencer à
fréquenter massivement le centre ville
qui en a beaucoup besoin
alors justement c'est ce que je vais
vous demander aux aléas de prioriser un
peu l'aménagement et le développement du
centre ville du centre bourgs plutôt que
les grandes zones industrielles par ci
par là mais qui font aussi que le
lamentait le coup - économie parce que
c'est l'échec sans quelques secondes
oui c'est l'insuffisance de la
municipalité sortante a c'est à dire en
fait c'est trente ans de gestion qui
s'arrête aujourd'hui avec le départ de
pièces un mot il faut tout revoir est la
priorité
pierre samot déjà partie civile est
toujours membre du conseil municipal à
vidzone tv
oui je sais bien que jamais il est
toujours membre du conseil municipal et
président encore des destitutions moi je
pense que je donne la priorité au
centre-ville refaire venir du monde
lave les quartiers doivent venir envahir
la ville cela suppose c'est une
d'équipement merci développer la
mobilité des citoyennes et des citoyens
c'est moi qui vous remercie pour votre
invitation merci eric valeur